[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
niedrigen sirion ihnen allem guten abend
katja stresow es mit mir im studio katja
viele fußball fans fragen sich gegen wen
muss deutschland bei der wm in katar an
ja das ist spannend in diesen sekunden
werden die gegner ausgelost eins kann
ich schon verraten spanien ist schon mal
dabei wer die anderen beiden sind wissen
wir gleich dann im sportblock wird
spannend unsere wichtigsten nachrichten
jetzt im überblick
vergebliche hoffnung auf hilfe mario
pohl bleibt abgeschnitten konvois mit
nahrung gelangen weiter nicht in die
zerstörte stadt
lebensmittel werden teurer infolge des
krieges in der ukraine kündigen erster
handelsketten kräftige preiserhöhungen
an
die masken dürfen fallen berlin
verzichtet seit heute auf corona
maßnahmen die meisten anderen
bundesländer folgen am wochenende
erstmals wirft russland der ukraine
einen angriff auf das eigene territorium
vor ukrainische hubschrauber sollen im
westen des landes ein treibstofflager
attackiert haben trotzdem verhandeln
beide seiten weiter über eine waffenruhe
besonders dramatisch bleibt die lage im
süden der ukraine wo russische truppen
die stadt mario pohl beschießen und
belagern weitere menschen sollen es
jetzt über einen flucht kurier aus der
stadt geschafft haben mehr jetzt von
achsen konrad und sarah alaska
endlich raus aus mario pohl endlich in
sicherheit sie sind auf eigene faust
geflohen aus der stadt der ruinen
wir haben glück dass die russen uns
nicht beschossen haben die zwei konvois
vor uns kamen unter feuer und mussten
umkehren
in marie obwohl weitere explosionen
weiter beschuss dabei sollte doch ab dem
morgen eigentlich eine waffenruhe gelten
damit es endlich klappt mit der
evakuierung tausender menschen damit
dringend benötigte hilfsgüter in die
stadt gebracht werden können
die busse vom roten kreuz haben sich
trotzdem auf den weg gemacht freie fahrt
zunächst aber die offenbar teuer erkauft
unglücklicherweise haben die besatzer
die humanitären hilfsgütern an sich
genommen 14 tonnen essen und medizin das
war der preis für die vereinbarung mit
dem roten kreuz für einen flucht
korridor
auch heute im norden bleibt unter
heftigem russischen beschuss einige
trauen sich in den feuerpausen raus
räumen auf suche nach verwertbaren am
sichersten aber ist es ganz tief unter
der erde hier haust svetlana mit ihrer
achtjährigen tochter anastasia seit
kriegsbeginn in diesem u bahnwaggon 20
meter unter der stadt kein tageslicht
seit einem monat aber tief genug um den
krieg wenigstens nicht zu hören
hier ist es noch sicherer in den gängen
über uns da hört man die bomben für
unsere psyche ist es hier unten besser
mein leben es gut hier mit all den
tieren aber ich träume davon dass
technik bald vorbei ist und die ukraine
gewinnt
und dann gibt es auch diese kurzen
momente der unbeschwertheit sie haben
eine show für die kleinen organisiert
ablenkung vom grauen über linien
und ganz in der nähe in belgorod auf
russischer seite erleben sie den krieg
im nachbarland plötzlich hautnah
zweikampf hubschrauber im tiefflug das
berichten die russen hätten ein
treibstofflager angegriffen und einen
großbrand ausgelöst
die russischen kräfte ist ihnen jetzt in
ihrer vor und barsten phase man versucht
eben deshalb funktion und treibstoff zu
treffen damit die verwundbare phase
möglichst lang anhält die ukrainische
seite will den angriff nicht
kommentieren wir sind nicht für jede
katastrophe auf russischem gebiet
verantwortlich heißt es lapidar
fragen wir nach ball christian seinem in
moskau christian was hat es mit diesem
mutmaßlichen angriff auf sich
ja da sind tatsächlich noch viele fragen
offen jetzt am abend eine stunde vor der
sendung hat sich der sprecher des
russischen verteidigungsministeriums zu
dem vorfall geäußert und gesagt diese 2
mi 24 kampfhubschrauber die hätten in
extrem niedriger höhe die grenze
überquert und dann dieses depot
geschossen unabhängig überprüfen lässt
sich das nicht über den tag hat er sich
kreml sprecher paskov auch dazu geäußert
und gesagt dieser zwischenfall der
überschatte rinn natürlich die
friedensgespräche die zwischen der
ukraine und russland stattfinden was
genau da stattgefunden hat das werden
wir vielleicht in den nächsten tagen
noch sehen aber insgesamt können wir
sagen dass natürlich bei solchen
zwischenfällen
die sorge wächst dass russland das zum
anlass nehmen könnte die militärische
aktivität in der ukraine zu erhöhen
vielen dank für diese hintergründe nach
moskau christiansen in diesen
kriegszeiten ist man entweder für oder
gegen putin fast alle mächtigen staaten
versuchen moskau zu sanktionieren und
isolieren außer china zwar fürchtet
peking wirtschaftliche konsequenzen aber
den russischen angriffskrieg verurteilen
will man nicht bei einem gipfeltreffen
mit der chinesischen führung versuchte
die eu heute einfluss zu nehmen und
warnte china vor mehr unterstützt für
russland florian neumann berichtet
dass die kommissionspräsidentin nicht
zurück winkmann versehen sein weil sie
gerade nicht auf den monitor blickt aber
es passt zum eisigen verhältnis zwischen
eu und china da schalten sich zwei
weltmächte zusammen die sich nur noch
wirtschaftlich blendend verstehen
heute war definitiv kein gewöhnlicher
gipfel er fand in der nicht eine
atmosphäre statt vor dem hintergrund des
russischen krieges gegen die ukraine
und vor dem hintergrund einer neuen
allianz gegen den westen die russland
und china bereits vor beginn des
russischen krieges geschmiedet hatten
seitdem kein kritisches wort chinas
gegen den russischen angriff aber auch
keine offene etwa militärische
unterstützung was die eu als ihre rote
linie definiert
wir hoffen dass unsere argumente die wir
mit nachdruck vorgebracht haben von der
chinesischen seite gehört werden wir
hoffen dass china dabei auch an sein
internationales ansehen denkt und an die
wirtschaftsbeziehungen zwischen china
und der europäischen union
die nämlich werden trotz politischer
eiszeit immer intensiver pro tag allein
handeln eu und china waren im wert von
1,9 milliarden euro sollte 2020 ist
china vor den usa der wichtigste
handelspartner der eu statt auf
sanktionen setzt europa deshalb auf die
kraft der argumente und hofft dass china
abrückt von russland das aber ist nach
dem gipfel von heute nicht zu erkennen
gehen wir zu ulf röller nach peking auf
die eu warnt china vor der unterstützung
moskaus was kann was darf europa von
china jetzt erwarten
ich glaube europa kann erwarten dass
china die sanktionen die gegen russland
fängt sind nicht unter läuft da wird
peking sehr genau darauf achten aus
einem ganz einfachen grund es ist ein
großes interesse für peking weiter ein
engere wirtschaftsbeziehungen mit europa
aufrecht zu erhalten man fürchtet wenn
man diese sanktion unterlaufen würde
gegen europa dass man dann selber
sanktioniert wird wird und nun hat kein
interesse in peking an einem
handelskrieg mit europa europa kann
allerdings nicht von china erwarten dass
es sich politisch loslässt loslöst vor
russland im gegenteil präsident sieht
die welt eigentlich aufgeteilt in diese
zwei blöcke auf der einen seite das
westliche bündnis und amerika und auf
der anderen seite eben russland und
china und china als führungs nation dort
präsident wird weiter versuchen einen
keil zumindestens langfristig zwischen
europa und amerika zu treiben um dieses
festliche bündnis zu schwächen also
insofern hat dieser gipfel heute auch
gezeigt die widersprüchlichkeit dieser
neuen weltordnung china will einerseits
europa politisch bekämpfen andererseits
die abhängigkeiten erhöht und man hat ja
gesehen wie gefährlich es ist wenn eben
abhängigkeiten mit diktaturen bestehen
besten dank für die analyse ulf röller
war das in peking mehr als vier
millionen menschen sind schon aus der
ukraine geflohen die meisten nach polen
viele auch nach deutschland wie viele
das weiß niemand genau registriert sind
bis jetzt fast
295.000 geflüchtete eine pflicht das zu
tun gibt es erst nach 90 tagen so lange
können sie sich ohne visum in der eu
aufhalten die kommunen wollen von
kanzler scholz mehr klarheit wie die
menschen im land schneller und gerecht
verteilt werden können dazu andrea
maurer
seit der flucht ist diese ukrainische
familie noch immer nirgendwo angekommen
sie waren in paris jetzt wollen sie
weiter wohin wissen sie noch nicht genau
eine irrfahrt der bahnhof mannheim
durchgangsstation nati tor hat abel hat
schon in der flüchtlingskrise 2015
ehrenamtlich geholfen ihr fehlt heute
die staatliche steuerung
also
2015/16 da gab es
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen die waren alle
einigermaßen relativ vorbereitet oder
man hat auch während der
der einreise der geflüchteten diese
strukturen aufgebaut aber jetzt merke
ich gar nichts davon wer ist zuständig
wie können die geflüchteten schneller
registriert besser verteilt werden
treffen der kommunalen spitzenverbände
heute mit kanzler ministerinnen und
ministern was konkret zu machen wir
haben in leipzig aktuell etwa acht bis
zehntausend menschen aus der ukraine die
eine erste aufnahme an einrichtungen die
anderen in privaten wohnungen sie zu
registrieren das zu bewältigen das wird
eine riesige herausforderung
eine generelle registrierung der
geflüchteten bei der einreise lehnt die
innenministerin bislang ab erschöpften
flüchtlingen sollen keine
grenzkontrollen zugemutet werden der
koalitionspartner fdp sieht das anders
ebenso die union ich würde eine
realisierung aller flüchtlinge für
besser halten weil wir dann genau wissen
wie viele menschen kommen wer kommt um
sie bedarfsgerecht versorgen zu können
die bundesregierung hat das problem zu
beginn unterschätzt weil sie auf eine
registrierung der angekommenen
verzichtet hat und das ist aber eine
ganz entscheidende voraussetzung die
länder und kommunen müssen ja wissen für
wie viele menschen sie beispielsweise
die unterbringung zu gewährleisten haben
politisch geht es nun auch um die frage
wer die kosten für die aufnahme
übernimmt die länder fordern vom bund
hilfe in milliardenhöhe
der bund will helfen aber verhandelt
noch über den umfang
jedenfalls gehört wenig phantasie dazu
sich vorzustellen dass sehr viele
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer weiterhin
jede menge hilfe benötigen und so ging
es über das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe
bahn.de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
stichwort zdf nothilfe ukraine und alles
zum nachlesen für sie auch unter spenden
zdf.de und auf der zdf text seite 89
immer stärker ist der ukraine krieg ja
jetzt auch im deutschen alltag zu spüren
und zwar nicht nur beim tanken oder
heizen lebensmittel verteuern sich
rasant
ein grund die hersteller müssen etwa für
weizen tierfutter und energie deutlich
mehr geld bezahlt das kommt jetzt in den
supermärkten an mit aufschlägen von 20
bis 50 prozent auf einzelne produkte
rechnet die branche am montag legt aldi
vor aber fast alle anderen ketten planen
nachzuziehen thomas münten berichtet
es gibt keine schlangen vor den aldi
märkten in deutschland heute ganz
normaler betrieb vor einem wochenende
ab montag werden beide aldi ketten vor
allem die preise für fleisch wurst und
milcherzeugnisse deutlich anheben bis zu
30 prozent könnte zb butter teurer
werden die verbraucher besorgt und
ratlos
da verdient man leider noch nicht so
viel und das ist für mich natürlich
ungünstig und ich würde es mir anders
wünschen das hat ja alles ursachen und
von daher
muss man damit wohl leben können der
discount riese geht voraus aber das ist
schon klar die anderen
lebensmittelhändler werden folgen müssen
ob rewe penny edeka netto oder lidl
es ist kein zimmer der discounter sein
das wird alle anderen supermärkte und
andere geschäfte auch mit betreffen und
für die verbraucher heißt es natürlich
dass sie sich darauf einstellen müssen
und typischerweise schlechter ist das
verbrauchervertrauen das kann auch noch
mal dazu führen dass bestimmte
anschaffungen getätigt werden den
verdacht dass die händler den
gestiegenen preisen mehr verdienen weiß
der verband klar zurück
in der tat tut der handel alles und wird
auch entsprechend preisforderung der
industrie genau prüfen aber leider sind
wir momentan eben auch nicht in der lage
diese kostenerhöhung selber aufzufangen
sondern müssen es weiter geben über die
preise an den interviews bis die
lebensmittelpreise wieder sinken kann es
nach schätzungen des institutes der
deutschen wirtschaft durchaus länger
dauern
mitten im ukraine kriegt diese meldung
ein ex reserveoffizier der bundeswehr
und wirtschaftsvertreter soll für einen
russischen nachrichtendienst spioniert
haben der vorwurf sechs jahre lieferte
ralf g russland wohl brisante
kontaktdaten wie auch informationen zu
nord stream 2 jetzt hat die
bundesanwaltschaft anklage erhoben wegen
spionage für russland
für rund 300 deutsche soldatinnen und
soldaten heißt es bald ab nach hause
ende des monats endet das mandat für die
eu mission atalanta seit 2008 war die
marine am horn von afrika stationiert
und halte unter anderem mit piraten
angriffe abzuwehren die gab es in der
region zeitweise hundertfach pro jahr
fanden zuletzt aber überhaupt nicht mehr
statt
die derzeitige corona welle hat ihren
höhepunkt nach einschätzung des robert
koch institutes möglicherweise schon
überschritten insbesondere bei jüngeren
zwischen 15 und 34 sei die inzidenz
rückläufig bei den über 60 jährigen
steige sie jedoch wieder an heute meldet
das lka 252 1530 neue infektionen
innerhalb eines tages
1968 weniger als vor einer woche
außerdem kamen 300 vier todesfälle hinzu
die sieben tage incident sinkt auf 1.506
und 80,4
die masken sie gehören für uns
inzwischen zum alltag jetzt am sonntag
fallen sie in fast allen bereichen und
fast allen bundesländern wie auch sonst
eigentlich die ganzen kroner maßnahmen
in berlin ging es schon heute los und
wie es dort lief in der hauptstadt das
erzählt uns jetzt romanesco war keine
masken pflicht mehr in der ständigen
vertretung seit heute setzt das berliner
restaurant auf freiwilligkeit für gäste
die personal der chef ist froh keine 3g
kontrollen mehr keine diskussionen als
vorstandsmitglied des berliner
gaststättenverbandes schätzt er aber
dass nicht alle betriebe so reagieren
also ich so höre ist so eine 50 50 also
ein teil will weiterhin an der masken
kriegt festhalten anderer teil nicht
kommt sicherlich auch auf die art der
gastronomie an komplett festhalten an
der masken pflicht wollen die
staatlichen museen mit hilfe des
hausrechts auch in der neuen
nationalgalerie heißt es daher weiter
zutritt nur mit mund nasen schutz das
soll auch helfen personelle engpässe zu
vermeiden die entscheidung ist wirklich
wir wollen sehen dass unsere kolleginnen
und kollegen die hier im haus arbeiten
möglich sicher sind weil es in den
ganzen tag hier und das wir stetig offen
sein können diffus die lage im
einzelhandel rund um den kudamm gibt es
jetzt geschäfte mit masken pflicht und
welche ohne manche setzen auf
freiwilligkeit andere achten nur darauf
dass es nicht zu voll wird egal was gilt
viele behielten die masken auf heute zu
den lockerungen gehen die meinungen
auseinander
es werden noch mal und das schöne das
gefällt mir gut in zahlen nach zu
urteilen ist es viel zu früh ich werde
weiter meine maske tragen einfach aus
gewohnheit mittlerweile schon gab es hat
zwei jahre lang diese masken pflicht und
auch einfach auf sicherheit eine hotspot
regel wie in anderen bundesländern wird
es in berlin vorerst nicht geben heißt
es aus der politik die korona lage gebe
dass derzeit nicht her
ja ab sonntag also greifen die neuen
regeln was genau dann wo erlaubt es das
können sie in unserer heute nachlesen
vom supermarkt bis zum restaurant und
wir haben auch aufgelistet was in den
bundesländern gilt die sich zu hot spots
erklärt haben wir verlassen die erde
gehen ins all denn dort ist jetzt ein
weiterer deutscher satellit es vor gut
einer halben stunde mit einer space ex
rakete in florida abgehoben ziel des
satelliten programms ist die bessere
erkundung der ökosysteme mehr zum
raketenstart und dem vorhaben von
brigitte sah
lift off cape canaveral in florida an
bord einer space extrakte geht es ins
all noch haben sie keinen kontakt zu dem
satelliten mit dem namen m ab der dann
erst mal ausgerichtet werden muss
satellit wird erst so gegen 20 uhr über
unsere erste antennen station fliegen
die es den norwegen und spitzbergen und
von dem moment an hat unser team alle
hände voll zu tun das besondere an dem
satelliten mit dem namen ändert er kann
neben dem sichtbaren bereich des lichts
auch besonders viele frequenz kanäle im
infrarotbereich auswerten die
detaillierte daten von der
beschaffenheit der erdoberfläche liefern
der haben die möglichkeit in 27 tagen
immer wieder über den gleichen ort
darüber zukommen das heißt es erlaubt
uns tatsächlich zeitreihen
aufzunehmen und daraus trends abzulesen
es geht darum großflächige veränderungen
der umwelt zu beobachten der satellit
kann zum beispiel die wasserqualität von
gewässern bestimmen messen in welchem
zustand wälder oder anbauflächen sind
und erkennen wie viel feuchtigkeit im
boden steckt wo kommt das wasser her wo
geht das wasser hin warum geht es dahin
und auf einmal nicht mehr dahin da haben
wir die dürren da haben wir die
überschwemmung auswirkungen des
klimawandels auf die umwelt fünf jahre
lang sollen wissenschaftler aus aller
welt durch nf jetzt neue detaillierte
daten zum klimawandel auf der erde
bekommen
der norden hat sein winter comeback ja
gestern schon gegeben jetzt zog das
schneetief über ganz deutschland bis
nach bayern über zehn zentimeter
neuschnee konnten es heute sein und so
mancher autofahrer waren darauf nicht
eingestellt es gab etliche
verkehrsunfälle mindestens bis sonntag
soll es winterlich bleiben der frühling
muss sich also noch ein bisschen
gedulden
schnee gehört zum winter winter nicht
unbedingt zu einer fußball-wm und doch
wird so kommt zumindest aus unserer
perspektive und wir erfahren jetzt mehr
über die gruppengegner deutschland es
wurde ausgelost für die wm die erste wm
im winter in katar das eröffnungsspiel
findet am 21 november statt das finale
kurz vor weihnachten am 18 dezember und
bei einer farbenfrohen gala wurden eben
gerade die gruppen ausgelost und
deutschland spielt in gruppe e gegen
spanien japan und gegen den sieger des
playoff spiels costa rica gegen
neuseeland markus harm ist live für uns
in doha markus wie sind die zugelosten
gegner einzuschätzen
ja man kann sagen im dfb ist das
losglück treu geblieben die gruppe ist
relativ einfach nach meiner einschätzung
das deutsche auftaktspiel am 23.11
findet gegen japan statt das zweite
spiel und das ist dann das schwierigste
gegen spanien das ist eine wiederauflage
des wm halbfinales von 2010 spanien
weltmeister 2010 europameister 2008 also
das ist schon ein harter brocken und
dann zuletzt noch gegen neuseeland oder
costa rica das wird noch ausgespielt
dieses spiel aber dennoch ein
weiterkommen denke ich sollte drin sein
für die deutsche mannschaft nur spanien
ist ein wirklich richtig ernst zu
nehmender gegner stehen dankbar kurs
alle gruppen dann auch im internet bei
uns unter zdf sport.de jetzt zum
frauenfußball die spielerinnen des vfl
wolfsburg gehören seit gestern abend zu
den vier top teams in europa sie
besiegten im viertelfinal-rückspiel die
frauen von arsenal london mit 2 zu 0
jubel bei den spielerinnen und ein
glückliches trainerteam wolfsburg
vollkommen verdient im
champions-league-halbfinale führung
minute durch rot die den ball vorbei
spitzentanz ins berger die entscheidung
dann in der zweiten halbzeit 73 minute
williams mit dem eigentor wolfsburg
trifft jetzt auf die beste frauen
fußballmannschaft der welt bevor das
jetzt auf barcelona auf die nächste
runde hier im stadion wahrscheinlich
unter dann hoffentlich leisten kann es
sind die wochen der wahrheit für
wolfsburg in der bundesliga wartet am
sonntag der fc bringen
und in der bundesliga der männer heißt
das spitzenspiel morgen und borussia
dortmund gegen rb leipzig der bvb für
den anschluss an die bayern die momentan
mit sechs punkten vorsprung die tabelle
anführen nicht verlieren und hofft auf
den einsatz seines spitzen stürmers kann
dortmund torjäger el in holon trotz
lädierten knöchels spielen gegen leipzig
im erstmals seit mehr als zwei jahren
voll besetzten heimischen stadion
berichten natürlich unbedingt aber wir
müssen morgen heute morgen einfach
schauen wie sich die dinge entwickeln
ein verblüffend klares daumen hoch für
holland dagegen vom gegnerischen trainer
wir planen dass er spielt mit der wird
auch spielen somit um am ring ist topp
spielte nicht nur für uns auch für sie
und da wird alles daran gesetzt dass er
spielt und er wird spielen musik in den
ohren aller bvb-fans mit roland und
ohrenbetäubenden fans im rücken wäre
dortmund gegen leipzig favorit
und die ersten bilder dieses spiels im
freetv morgen mit einem aktuellen
sportstudio vielen bank ja zum wetter so
viel der schneefall ist noch nicht
vorbei mehr details gleich von katja
horneffer um 22 uhr empfehle ich ihnen
das heute journal mit christian sievers
von uns war es dass wir von heute 19
team danken für das interesse wünschen
einen entspannten start ins wochenende
schönen abend und bis morgen
[Musik]
guten abend das schneetief lotte brachte
heute verbreitet zwischen zwei und zwölf
zentimeter schnee allerdings ist der
regen noch nicht überall in schnee
übergegangen hier im süden da ist es
derzeit noch regen das wird sich aber in
der nacht ändern dann geht der regen
auch dort in schnee über machen sie sich
also auf fünf bis 15 zentimeter
neuschnee gefasst es wird glatt auf
straßen und auf gehwegen im osten und
dem nordosten dagegen kommt kein schnee
mehr runter dazu pfeift immer noch ein
böiger wind aus nord nordöstlichen
richtungen die temperaturen sinken auf
plus 2 bis minus fünf grad und morgen
bleibt es in der südhälfte kalt mit
temperaturen um den gefrierpunkt milder
wird es im norden mit fünf bis acht grad
denn dort reißen die wolken auseinander
und sie sehen häufig die sonne im süden
sieht anders aus dem saarland rheinland
pfalz in baden-württemberg und bayern da
schneit es vor allen dingen am vormittag
noch kräftig weiter im laufe des tages
ziehen sich die schneefälle an den
alpenrand zurück und am sonntag wird es
freundlich und frisch bei temperaturen
von zwei bis zehn grad dann kommen neue
regenwolken von nordwesten heran guten
abend